in and around Banff National Park his
exploits are legendary the boss a
Grizzly as big as they come he's also
really good at occupying habitats around
people without coming into conflict with
people and so that kind of just creates
this scenario where he is well loved
over the years the boss has made plenty
of headlines there was the time he was
spotted eating a black bear or when he
survived being hit by a train he's also
believed to have fathered more than 70
percent of the area's Cubs
but while hearing about his Legend is
easy in these parts seeing the bear up
close in person is another story
so when award-winning nature
photographer Jason Leo bantle spotted a
set of fresh Grizzly tracks in the snow
he went to investigate at this time of
year you don't want to go follow a
grizzly bear so I actually followed the
grizzly bear backwards I followed his
Trail backwards I just had curiosity I
did a masters in biology and I love to
know about animals after finding the
Bear's Den bantle returned to his
vehicle and I couldn't believe it about
a half a kilometer down there was yeah
the back of a bear with snow on it it
was glistening in the sunlight from the
safety of his car battle was able to
capture these rare and up close images
of the boss and that evening in the
evening light as the sunset he came
through the meadow and just this
beautiful lumbering bear and his element
the encounters made all the more
meaningful because of the animal's age
the boss is believed to be over 20 years
old and Grizzlies typically live 20 to
25. it's why bantle doesn't take these
stunning images for granted or the time
he got to spend and in the presence of a
local Legend he's the boss there's no
question about it
Heather urich's West Global News